foreign
we're gonna get started when we started
this place and some of you may know the
collection of books that we keep here is
called the manual for civilization so
it's the it's the idea of making a book
collection of the of the 3000 books you
would most want to sustain or restart
civilization and uh I had I had found
this poster that was this poster of the
things that you would want in a time
machine if you went back in time to
reinvent technology was the very first
thing that we hung up in this space
and I didn't realize at the time that it
was connected to the person who did
dinosaur Comics who I was a huge fan of
and when I realized this was all the
same person uh one of the people that I
wanted more than anything else
just to have here in the space was Ryan
North
and so I'm so glad that we after all
this time and a pandemic and his very
first travel away from home that we get
to uh that we get to have him welcome
Miranda
thank you
this is me uh
this is me before pandemic look how
happy look how innocent
he's learned a lot so yes I am the guy
who started dinosaur Comics 20 years ago
tomorrow is a 20th anniversary of
dinosaur comics thank you if you don't
know what it is it's a webcomic where I
use the same pictures and I change the
words it's better than it sounds because
it sounds pretty horrible it's a lot of
fun if you don't know me from that you
might uh you don't know me at all you
could maybe discover me through print
Comics like Adventure Time comics
Squirrel Girl Comics
Fantastic Four I've done non-linear
adaptations of Shakespeare and a sequel
to that I've done comics for Archie I've
done picture books I've done short story
Anthology sequels to short story
anthologies I've adapted Slaughterhouse
Five into a graphic novel which was
awesome and terrifying and I also the
most recently done some Star Trek Comics
so I do a bunch of different stuff but
I'm here today because I want to talk to
you about not this book this is my most
recent book that I just came out about
taking over the world but today we're
going to talk about a different book
called How to invent everything and my
process of research in creating this
book so this is the how to invent how to
invent everything presentation and it
begins with this colorful character who
you might recognize he's Marty McFly
from Back to the Future I saw this movie
when I was six years old and I spent the
next
30 years thinking about it basically and
what I like so much is that in this
story Marty goes back in time I'm going
to spoil the plot of Back to the Future
here
Marty McFly goes back in time and has
some Adventures causes some problems and
at one point he's at the Enchantment of
the Sea dance and he's playing rock and
roll and he's plagiarizing Chuck Berry
and who is at that performance but
Marvin Berry Chuck's cousin who calls up
Chuck and said you know that new sound
you're looking for listen to this and
then Chuck presumably here's his own
music from the future and thinks this is
great I too will plagiarize this and
yeah this this time Loop where
whoever first wrote that song is now
erased from the creativity of this it's
not like the universe invented itself
and that idea of taking some technology
or art or anything back in time
and then saying I did this this is my
thing I created this really interesting
really really fascinated me and I wanted
to sort of explore that idea
and
there are a lot of people who look at
this idea of time travel which to our
knowledge is is not possible and so you
know it's probably fine probably exists
here's here's a clip from YouTube It's a
woman for 1938 and well look what she's
doing there she's talking on her cell
phone she's 100 talking on her cell
phone you look at the YouTube comments
and they're like time travel is real the
government is lying to you none of them
realizing cell phone is a piece of
technology that relies on other pieces
of Technology a cell phone in 1938 is
not going to let you talk to anyone a
because no one else has a cell phone and
B the required towers and all this
infrastructure technology exists on a
web of other technology you can't just
bring a cell phone back in time and
expect it to work and then the other
complaint about this image this video
clip is that it's not a cell phone
it's a hearing aid
technology changes over time and early
hearing aids you'd hold to your ears you
could hear what people were saying this
is just a handheld way to hear the
people around you but to our Modern Eyes
it looks like she's clearly talking a
cell phone because that's what we do
these days when we hold something to our
ears the more advanced version
so I had this idea to make a book where
it would actually be a guide to
rebuilding civilization from scratch at
any point in human history and
what got me really excited about this
project was it was going to be the most
dangerous book in human history if time
travel was ever invented because you
drop this book at any point in history
you changed everything and I was like
this is great I love a dangerous book
I'm going to write I'm going to write
the most dangerous book in human history
and then I went to the bookstore and I
saw this book and I was like I'm going
to write the second most dangerous book
in human history
so if you ever get a time machine do not
put this book in your times take my book
instead
so I had this idea I wanted to write a
manual free building civilization with
you if you had a time machine and that
requires figuring out what the time
machine is and I wanted I had this
premise in my head of you go back in
time when the time machine breaks and so
you open up the repair guide of this
kind of cruddy time machine it's not
going to be fancy it's not going to be
high tech it's going to be like a rental
market time machine and you open up the
manual and it says hey you know Welcome
To The Past sorry your time machine
broke down you're kind of out of luck
the time machine is the most
complicated machine Humanity has ever
created and you're not going to fix it
in the past so sorry here's how to
rebuild civilization here's how to bring
the future back to you
and with this idea of a rental market
time machine I needed to have a theory
of time travel that made it work so I
said okay it's really irresponsible to
send people back in time and let them
stomp on all these butterflies and
change the timeline because you would
erase your own existence so the time
machine sends you back in time creates a
new timeline and when you return you go
back to the present nice fictional
theory of time travel that makes it
less unethical to send people into the
past and let's use it for like resource
extraction and all sorts of very
questionable things so I call my time
machine the FC 3000 it looks like this
we had a robot drawn on chalkboard
because we live in the future
and tonally
and the past uh tonally I was really
inspired by airplane safety manuals
where they go over this you know
horrible thing
and make it seem Almost Boring like oh
yeah you know if the plane crashes we'll
just exit in an orderly fashion it'll be
fine
so that corporate tone of you know
you're trapped in the past and things
are horrible but it'll be let's just
follow the instructions you'll be fine
so we have the time machine I label all
the parts which was great because it
turned 30 years of watching Star Trek
into a skill because I could very easily
rattle off the polarity aligned Einstein
Rose and Bridge generator or the Planck
inhibitor shunt you can just I can talk
for days about imaginary technology
super easily
and so now the step is to write the book
right I've got the idea for the book
I've got this whole premise all I need
to do is write it and I sat down on my
computer and I felt a lot like this
sequence which is a Batman comic if
you're gonna feel like someone feel like
Batman this is a early Batman year One
he's not yet Batman yet he's still Bruce
Wayne and I'll read it to you I'll do my
Batman voice so he's
101 he's saying I'm not ready I have the
means the skill but not the method
no that's not true I have hundreds of
methods but something's missing
something's not right I have to wait I
have to wait and he's like kicking a
tree in half he's ready
Bruce does not need to wait at this
point and so I felt like that I felt
like there's something missing what do I
need to do and I kind of started to feel
like oh no
this book I want to write is impossible
because no one has written it yet and
it's really hard to collapse
civilization into a couple hundred pages
and the only solution to that is after
you start feeling really bad for your
life choices you sit down and try to
write a little bit of it and after
writing a little bit of like okay it's
not impossible it's just really really
hard and I think about really really
hard is you can work with really really
hard
so I did all this research
and I started to write
and I discovered a trend in the
information I was gathering and
assimilating
usually when you look at popular science
books there's a tone of Triumph look at
what we have created look how smart we
are we're really good at this being
human inventing things thing and I was
finding this
tone I guess that
you don't see often which is we're not
as smart as we think we are
and
I kind of want to walk you through a
couple of the examples I found in which
that was the case in which we had
of everything we needed
to invent a piece of technology and then
didn't do it for a really astoundingly
long period of time and usually it was
because we were laboring under a bad
hypothesis we thought something was true
that wasn't
so the first example is this beautiful
stock footage I purchased of a compass
so
here's the compass they could have been
vented in 200 BCE this is when the
ancient Greeks started noticing they had
these lodestones that were naturally
magnetic they were actually invented in
o1000 CE which is 1200 years of time
between the two and you'll think okay
well you know compasses are pretty
complicated that's a tiny sliver of
metal balanced on a pin sandwich between
two layers of plastic I can see why that
would take some time but when the
compass was invented in China around
1000 CE first it was used for fortune
telling for 100 or so years before it
was used for navigation
and these first compasses were not the
the plastic thing I was describing if
you have a lodestone a piece of magnetic
material it's naturally going to want to
turn to point towards midnight North
to allow it to freely turn you just have
to tie your rock to a string the string
supports The Rock The Rock rotates
freely tying a rock to a string took us
over a thousand years
to figure out because we were operating
under this bad hypothesis that some
rocks are just weird
I'll give you another example
uh beautiful stock footage of a cute dog
and a stethoscope so stethoscopes could
have been invented in 300 BCE this is
when we first came up with paper they
were actually invented in oh 1816 CE the
story here is you have this Victorian
doctor uh man heterosexual
and he has a theory that the sounds that
bodies make could be diagnostic as a
medical professional and so he's been
pressing his ear to his patient's chest
and then one day he has a patient
female basti and he's like this is too
erotic for me
I simply cannot press my ear to that
chest I need to leave room for Jesus and
so
he rolls up some paper and makes the
tube uses that and discovers by accident
that the tube isolates and enhances the
sounds he's trying to hear that we're in
fact Diagnostic and so it took us 2 000
years between when we could have met the
test scope and did and this was the only
example in my research that I found of
actual scientific progress being made by
someone who was too horny to do their
job properly so it did pay off in this
instance
that hypothesis paper is boring and I
hate it
another piece of technology you all
recognize these this is these are
buttons
not really a
difficult thing to figure out
so they could have invented in 2800 BCE
this is when we first found evidence of
humans tying pretty rocks and shells to
their clothing to make themselves look
nicer actually invented in around 1200
CE which is 4 000 years of space and
what's killer is that the button is a
great piece of technology it allows
clothes to be form-fitting you have to
fit them over your head it allows them
to be sturdier and
we spent 4 000 years
thinking we looked pretty good with
these nice shells attached to our shirts
when really we looked like idiots who
didn't know how a button worked didn't
want to put a slit in the other side to
seal clothing so you know not our not
our greatest hour or 4 000 years and the
bad hypothesis we had here was that
Fashion Is Never practical
give you another example this image of
milk represents the process of
pasteurization so pasteurization is a
process in which you take a food you
bring it up to almost the boiling point
then you let it cool this kills the
bacteria in the food make it much more
safer to drink milk without
pasteurization is really dangerous food
to drink when it's been left out for a
while with pasteurization it becomes one
of the safest could have invented around
10 500 BCE this when we first started
doing farming we first started having
animals we might want to drink their
milk regularly actually invented in 1117
CE and then reinvented in the 1800s by
Louis Pasteur who puts his name all over
it
eleven thousand five hundred years where
we could have had this technology and
didn't which is
I will say it I mean I'm a human so my
best friends are humans but this is
pretty embarrassing for all of us
that hypothesis food goes bad sometimes
oh well nothing we can do
one last example of this hot air
balloons
symbolizing the human dream of flight
the most uh canonical example of humans
striving to be more than what they are
we we want to fly we finally achieve it
with lighter than air flight with hot
air balloons could have been invented in
200 BCE this is where in China they come
up with paper lanterns which can fly
they have everything they need right
there actually invented in 1783 CE by
the mongolfier brothers in France and
the Fair brothers are great
because they have no idea what they're
doing they have a fire and they discover
that this sack on top elevates and they
say oh my God we just discovered
Mongolia gas which allows things to fly
so we'll build a big Mongolia balloon
and fill it with Mongol Fair Gas and
people be able to fly and it works
what they don't realize is that their
whole theory behind it is wrong it's
just that less dense air flows to the
top and that's what makes things fly
that's two thousand years we could have
had it and didn't but it actually gets
worse because the mongolia's first
balloon wasn't the silks you saw on the
previous slide it was a burlap sack
lined with paper and you can make a
burlap sack lined with paper out of
natural plant and animal fibers if you
knew what you were doing one person
working alone over the course of their
life could easily collect enough fiber
to make a big burlap sack line it with a
lot of paper and achieve the Eternal
dream of human flight
at any point in human history
so these were
fun things to discover about our shared
past but if you are going back in time
there are a lot of things that you can
reinvent and take the credit for and
it's not just technology there's things
in art and music that also
can be plagiarized if you want to call
it that from the present and brought
back to the past obviously with art art
styles is something that we invented and
you can take the credit for different
styles put them in different areas but
even art has technological aspects
attached to it a great example here is
perspective this is single point
perspective everything goes towards a
single vanishing point we all learned
this in art class in maybe grade one or
two it's the way to draw cool things in
3D
but the fact that single-point
perspective everything goes towards a
single vanishing point
we had to figure that out and before we
figure that out
even with multiple point perspective we
had some troubles
um here's a painting from the 600s CE
where
the artist is clearly wanting to draw in
perspective but he's he's struggling a
bit you can see here the table is sort
of wonky dispatching points over here
this one's over here I'm not sure what's
going on with this cabinet but he
doesn't have a coherent theory of how
things receive just knows that they do
in some way without the technology of
perspective he can't draw things
properly in a realistic way and you
could argue that okay well this was this
was a style at the time everyone liked
things to look this wonky and they could
have drawn up respect they just didn't
want to but that argument is kind of uh
undermined by noticing that when we do
figure out the rules of perspective
artists go Hog Wild for it it happened
in the Renaissance in Europe da Vinci
1495 CE this is a sort of a hard piece
of art to look at with fresh eyes
because we've all seen it so often but
if you do look at that with fresh eyes
you can see that it's about five percent
religion and 95 of like bro check it out
I can draw in perspective I got cubes or
squares on the wall I got squares on the
ceiling they're sitting at a nice
rectangle in a flat plane it is Da Vinci
showing off that he can draw a 3D
picture and make it look great it's not
just Da Vinci Raphael philosophers
famous work in the western Canon around
the same time and Raphael can draw a
friggin Cube there's one there's one
there's one there's one
these are just elongated cubes these
steps he's very excited to show off what
he's what he can do now with this new
technology and reminds me nothing more
than
of
images in like the late 80s early 90s
where he figured out Ray tracing and
everyone was doing Chrome spheres over
checkerboard patterns or like when we
when we get lens flares to work you get
a lot of that showing up all of a sudden
people like to play with new toys art
music another piece of technology
obviously the way you write music down
is technological but also the songs
themselves are pieces of art you can
take back in time and take the credit
for and so in the book I put in a bunch
of different songs and the funny stories
I wanted to put in uh Shoop by salt and
pepper
and so I emailed the people holding the
right to the music and I said there's no
sheet music for shoot for some reason
I'd love to make some what does that
cost
and they said is this for a textbook and
I was like no no it's like you read it
for fun but it's also like this it's
real information it's real science so
it's kind of a textbook but not really
and it's about time travel but it's
non-fiction about time travel and uh
they ask again if it was a textbook and
I said no it's not a textbook and I
explained the project more and they
stopped replying to me
so instead I put in a public domain song
the theme to Tetris is a Russian folk
song so I got that transcribed by a
musician I know who had never played
Tetris so it is absolutely the Russian
version of this and not the Tetris theme
the song even though they're the same
song
but this also technology around music
which
I found super fascinating so this
invention here is called the hooks wheel
and the way it works
is that hook the gentleman here who
invented it turns this large wheel it's
attached to a smaller wheel to make the
smaller wheel turn faster
on a smaller wheel there's teeth
of a known quantity
and you hold a tiny sliver of wood
against those teeth and if you've ever
ridden a bike and put a baseball card in
the wheel and spokes the wheel
you know that as the wheel spins faster
at the clicks blur together and the
frequency gets higher the faster the
text goes like click click click click
[Music]
when hook invented this wheel it was the
first time in human history that you
could hear a sound at a known frequency
which was very useful because there was
a thing in music at the time called tone
inflation where people are like you know
what higher music is more beautiful and
so musicians would tune their
instruments higher and higher and higher
until they began to exceed the range of
human voices and the vocalists would be
like we can't sing this High you gotta
bring it down and towns even pass laws
about how high things could be Hook's
wheel allowed them a set of frequency
now when you go to an orchestra when
they're tuning up that first note is
a440 it's an a note at 440 Hertz coming
all the way back to hooks wheel he
thought this would make him a lot of
money but the problem is once you only
need one hooks wheel and then you can
invent the tuning fork you get the wheel
to do 440 Hertz you make your tuning
fork metal you shape it down until the
same tone you no longer need hooks wheel
so it didn't get in fame or Fortune but
it did allow us to actually quantify
sound for the first time
something you want to do if you're
Reinventing the theme to Tetris in the
distance past
you're also going to want to
there's Foods you'll want to reproduce
in the past a lot of the food we today
benefits from selective breeding we've
made plants that we found in nature and
we've made them more suitable to our
purposes by just breeding them the way
we want it and the nice thing about
selective breeding is it's a technology
that you kind of get for free if you are
farming and you have a plant that's
giving you more fruits or more of
anything you think is desirable you will
automatically plant more of that plant
trying to get more of it and over time
that gives an evolutionary pressure to
make it evolve into a more convenient
version of that same with animals
so corn is a great example of a thing we
have selectively bred the heck out of
the
first domesticated around 7000 BCE and
the corn we enjoy today America land of
corn don't want to explain to you what
corn is but it's juicy delicious easy to
eat peels easily and has about 600 soft
kernels the earliest version of corn is
a grain called Tia site and it is much
smaller you peel it by Smashing it into
pieces it tastes like a dry raw potato
and you only get about five to ten very
hard kernels per piece of corn so food
is going to be disappointing in the past
just what I'm trying to say here Peach
is another great example modern version
of peach nine to one flesh to Stone
ratio
soft and edible skin sweet and juicy
first investigate around 5500 BCE the
incredibly disappointing agent ancestor
of a peach is a lot closer to a cherry
it's a lot smaller and nine to two flesh
to Stone ratio waxy skin taste earthy
sour and slightly salty just a garbage
Peach with potential with potential
watermelon is a great example too first
investigate around 3000 BC modern
variety it's huge you can get it
seedless you just punch your way into it
delicious taste sweet smell and almost
fat and starch free I discovered the
ancient watermelons were much smaller
you get about bitter and nutty seeds
inside of them you need a hammer it like
get smashed your way in really hard high
in starches and fats like don't don't
waste your time with this bitter taste
unpleasant smell this is an image from
The Book Table seven food used to suck
but the neat thing about watermelon is
that we have continued to selectively
breed the watermelon and thanks to the
European tradition of still life
portraiture we can actually see the
evolution of watermelon over recent
history 1600s
look at this watermelon the pith is huge
the seeds are huge you see the melon
part of it really showing through
same time period this watermelon is very
pithy very melony not very attractive
I had 100 years you're seeing less of
the pith there the seeds are still
prominent but it's more approximating
what we're used to go ahead another
hundred years you can still see some of
the melon structure the meat of the
melon still there the seeds are getting
smaller around the 1864.
and then the modern amount of watermelon
seedless little tiny white seeds like we
have finally given the watermelon its
true form what it was always meant to be
we've allowed the watermelon to fully
Express itself and become the ultimate
form of watermelonness this is what
humans can do given time and dedication
but there's also some foods that you
can't reproduce in the past that you can
enjoy today and you can't reproduce them
if you go back in time
great example here is the pink red
grapefruit there
um
so the back story here is that in the
50s nuclear power had a bad rap thanks
to atomic bombs and
the US government wanted to sort of how
do we remediate this how do we make
nuclear power
good for people make it may have a good
reputation and so since it's the 50s
they start a program with the most 50s
name in the world which is Atoms for
Peace and they create through the Atoms
for Peace program gamma Gardens where
you put a radioactive core in the middle
of the garden and put plants in
concentric circles around that core the
plants closest to the Core
totally die plants furthest away are
least effective and the plants in the
middle mutate and one of those random
mutations turned the grapefruit into
this newer grapefruit that was lasted
longer on the Shelf tasted less sour and
was easier to ship becomes the more
popular grapefruit and the grapes you
enjoy today are usually descendants of
this
gamma irradiated fruits that we created
in the 50s as an experiment
so you can create this in the past once
you get that same random radiation
induced mutation which is very unlikely
to happen so don't
don't look forward to a lot of delicious
grapefruits in the past
there's others the avocado is a
fascinating case this is the Haas
avocado most avocados you buy are the
house avocado so
story here
is that you have this guy Mr Haas and he
is an avocado
farmer Speculator and what he likes to
do is grow avocado trees with real
sturdy bases and then graft on the
branches of other breeds of avocados
that produce Delicious Fruit
and so he pays this other gentleman Mr
Rideout to go around town and like fish
avocado seeds out of the garbage from
restaurants anywhere you can find me
gets paid by the seed give them to Mr
Haas
so Mr Rhino shows up with the seed Mr
Haas plants it a plant grows he's like
great I'm going to use this for grafting
okay grab some branches on they don't
take
he tries again next year they don't take
Haas says this is a garbage plant I'm
going to cut it down
and then another man Mr cocking shows up
and he says
maybe don't cut down that tree I have a
good feeling about that tree so he
doesn't the tree starts producing its
own fruit a fruit it produces year round
like other avocados which only do it
seasonally the fruit transports better
it's a superior avocado and you only get
it with a Mr Haas a mystery Rideout and
Mr Caulkins in the right place at the
right time and if you're looking for an
example of someone who's like maybe it's
a time traveler caucus is really
suspicious he starts off and says don't
cut down that tree see you never and now
we have the avocado
coin's another great example because we
have tried to recreate corn from Tia
site and we failed we've never been able
to selectively breed a new breed of corn
from the original TSI we don't know if
it was a random cross-pollination or
mutation that was just lucky but
we have not been able to make new corn
from the original Asian ancestor which
suggests it might be really hard of your
trap in the past to bring back the corn
you enjoy you can definitely try but I'm
just saying there's a
danger you might not succeed here so be
aware of that
we have not managed to reproduce corn
yet
so
after all this you might be wondering
well what's the what's the most
important invention of all to bring back
in time like of all these things in your
research Ryan
what's the big one what's the
the motherload of inventions
but I think maybe it's medicine uh
knowing what the organs do
help us out a lot it helped us get past
the idea that disease was caused by bad
smells or an imbalance of humors or
angry Gods it took us a long time as a
species to figure out what the organs do
because most cultures have a taboo
against cutting open bodies I'm told it
feels really weird I haven't done it
but it's it's challenging to do
autopsies so people kick that candy on
the road and end up not knowing what the
heart does or how blood moves through
the veins and all that stuff so that's a
great maybe that's a really important
example
um
maybe chemistry is a great thing to know
in the past maybe that's number one it
unlocks a whole
host of related inventions this is an
image from the book so don't use this in
real life if you're trying to do some
chemistry because I assume once you
haven't once you've had a time machine
that's the last invention you'll ever
need to make you just go to the Future
and steal their inventions and so I
tried to make the ultimate periodic
table and I stopped at element 172
because it seemed like an element 173
the electrons in the outer shell have to
travel faster than light and that seemed
like a pretty good place to stop of your
impossible elements
but it's not medicine it's not chemistry
that are the the most important
invention in my opinion
and to tell you what the most important
invention is we have to go back 200 000
years to what are called anatomically
modern humans so this is where humans
first have skeletons Anatomy that looks
identical to ours these are humans where
if you could go back in time and take
steal one of their babies and bring it
back to the present and raise it as your
own child that child would be just as as
clever and inventive and creative as any
other baby born today they've got the
nature they just don't have the nurture
but what happens once we have Anatomy
modern humans is 150 000 years later we
start getting behaviorally modern humans
these are humans who are acting like us
they're creating art they're bearing
their death or stuff that they're doing
things that we recognize as being
intrinsically human
and so the question is what changed what
brought us from anatomically modern
humans to behaviorally modern humans
there's a lot of theories about it but
the one that I think is really
compelling is that we started talking to
each other we invented language and
language may seem like a weird thing for
an invention because it feels innate it
feels like we kind of get it for free it
doesn't feel like a technology but it is
it's something that humans invented for
themselves and like any technology it
can be lost and what does language do
for you
so many things it lets you collaborate
with others it lets you express more
complex thoughts both out loud and
inside your own head many of us think
with language because it lets us nail
down otherwise amorphous thoughts it's
very easy to say you know let's meet
your cousin's third sister at the red
house around the corner three weeks from
Wednesday but it's hard to conceptualize
that without the words to nail down
those Concepts
so language also lets ideas survive the
death of the post I can say something
and then die and then that idea can live
on but without language you don't get
that speaking as we've been doing
talking is only half of the problem of
inventing language the other half is
writing you need writing too
with just talking you have an oral
tradition ideas can still travel through
generations but they get in they're
vulnerable to change writing lets ideas
arrive in the present with minimal
change it lets you communicate with
people who are out of earshot it lets
you community people who aren't even
alive yet when you're writing and it
lets you ship information around the
world with no more difficulty or expense
than shipping grain less actually
because books don't go bad
and it also lets you communicate with
people
not after you've died even after they've
died when everyone who speaks your
language and in your culture is dead the
deciphering of the ancient Egyptian
hieroglyphs being the greatest example
of that
so the first time we ever invented
written language was in Mesopotamia with
cuneiform it was initially used as a way
to keep track of taxes and stock and
basically a very human idea like I need
to know who owes me what and we expanded
it out into let's also write down our
hopes and dreams and theories and
everything else
and this is the first ever
language that humans came up with
independently it also was independently
invented in mesoamerica
with olmec's script and it was
possibly invented in China the
difficulty here is that China and
Mesopotamia aren't that far apart and
there's a chance that Mesopotamians did
not obey the prime directive and
culturally contaminated the Chinese with
this idea of language because it seems
like the hard part of inventing writing
is not the particulars of the script
it's this idea this big idea of taking
invisible sounds and turning them into
visible shapes that carry the same
meaning
so great we've got talking we've got
writing problem solved forever right
this is settled but it's not because of
this this is a script from Easter Island
the rapanui people Europeans show up to
East Rowland they found this script and
they said what is this and the rapunui
people said oh yeah this is our writing
but only the elites can read it so we
can't personally speak to I can't tell
you what this says but our leaders can
tell you what it says this is our form
of writing and the Europeans say great
and they continue slave raids and
disease and ecological collapse and they
come back 100 years later
and they say hey what's going on with
this uh this Rango rongo writing and
the people living the island the rapid
new people reply oh well we um only the
elites could read that and they're dead
there's no one left alive who can read
this language which is the most
terrifying thing I can think of it's so
wild
these shapes which perhaps once held
meaning are now just squiggles they're
empty and I say perhaps because we've
never been able to decipher this it has
some properties of language but we can't
tell if this was ever a language or if
it is just
imitating a language because everyone
who spoke it or claimed to speak it or
claimed to read it died language is a
technology and like any technology it
can be lost which is
terrifying so
independent inventions of language
the latest was possibly the rapanui
people in the 1800s going to the BCE
part of the calendar we have
Mesopotamians with uniform we have
mesoamericans we have the Chinese
and that's about it this big idea of
written language occurred maybe four
times plus or minus a few in all of
human history
which suggests that this is
a hard thing to come up with despite its
amazing utility this transformative
nature on society and people and the
earliest time the earliest invention of
written language
was in 3200 BCE
that is 45 000 years between the
revolution of behaviorally modern people
and writing forty five thousand years if
you go back to anatomically modern
people that is 196
000 years where we could have had this
technology and didn't and this is where
you can have the single greatest impact
on the planet with a time machine go
back to those anatomically modern people
teach them to talk teach them to express
themselves when you're done teach them
to write their thoughts down you'll be
giving every civilization on the planet
a 196 000 year Head Start this is where
you can have the greatest effect on time
with a time machine
so summing it all up I believe we're all
smart enough for evil civilization from
scratch it is a surprisingly achievable
thing to do
I believe there is so much low-hanging
fruit in history I was worried writing
this book that there would be not enough
to fill out the book how can I have
inventions that one person working alone
can do if they know what they're doing
and I could very easily fill this book
with so many cool things
and the third is that we're not special
we all tend to think that we are living
in a special era in history and yes
people in the past couldn't put these
pieces they had in their hands together
in the right way to invent things but we
definitely could so everything is done
and there's no more low-hanging fruit in
society and I don't believe that's the
case I think there's probably still
amazing things that we have everything
we need to invent and haven't yet put
together in this right way I think
that's a very inspiring thing but we
right now are living in the Futures Past
every day we can make choices to bring
about A Better Tomorrow based on what
we're doing right now and have a
butterfly effect go in the direction we
want so
we can all do things
every day to to bring about this better
tomorrow and feel like we are having the
effect of Marty McFly in the past
right now
okay thank you my pleasure this was
absolutely everything that I I had hoped
that we would get
um
the
I also want to thank you very much for
using five digit dates uh in Long now
fashion uh so that these can be read
into the next uh Deca Millennium yep
it's Future Ready and I I'm curious did
you did you figure out like what your
definition of technology is through this
book yeah I'd love to play with the idea
of what definitions of Technology are
yeah it boiled down to me this I think I
said in the talk something you don't get
for free
so
if you in a human body
don't
show up in the world with it then I
would call that technology it's
something that humans are making for
themselves to make the world easier
change it in some way and that's a very
broad view of technology I suspect but
that's what we're all starting with
right if you go back in time 200 000
years
you're seeing these antially wanted
people you you have to start with that
and what what do we build on from that
and then it becomes okay it's all
technology so it's a very
Broadview I suspect
well yeah I mean I think it's
interesting I mean when you talk about
language as a technology or writing as a
technology and we take these things and
I think like one of the founders of long
now has one of my favorite definitions
of technology which is every everything
that doesn't quite work yet
and so you know we we off and then so
it's this idea of the things that you're
still working on whereas everything else
the things that that already work are
the things that you just take for
granted are just like air and water
that's interesting because I mean I can
put language in that in that box there's
um a great research paper I read in the
past life as a computational linguist a
grad student where the open question was
why does language evolve so quickly like
why can
we look at a book from a hundred years
ago and say that's super dated and look
at a book from 400 years ago and say I
can barely read this Shakespeare it
seems like it's almost a foreign
language and look at what our parents
were saying as slang 30 years ago and be
like that's so embarrassing how could
they ever talk that way and one of the
theories was that language is not just
hard to learn as an adult and it's
easier as a child but even as a child
like we you all taught yourself a
language by hearing it spoken around you
and reverse engineering everything from
that which is the most impressive thing
I can imagine but
the argument was well maybe language is
not just hard to learn maybe it's
impossible to learn maybe we can never
speak the language of our parents or
those around us we're just approximating
it we're getting 90 of the way there
allows us to communicate easily it
allows us to express we need to it does
the job but those edges that we never
quite copy
allow us to have it evolve very quickly
because we don't know what we're doing
wrong because
that's the way our parents speak and
that explains
a lot of why language can be so
transformed so quickly and I think
that's
I think it's really cool so put in the
thing of things that don't quite work is
all human communication
the I mean the other one that always
really gets me and you know we're
building a clock that's trying to last
for thousands of years and so I've done
a lot of research into various clock
things uh from the past and so there's
this thing called the anticothera device
which yes absolutely no yep
um but it it was a technology that was
invented
it it did things like show you how
various celestial events as well as
things like differential gearing or it's
didn't show up again for 1500 years yes
but there's absolutely no reason and it
clearly was not the first device of its
time yep but I'm curious your take on
the intake a third device oh it's sad so
yeah this is a this is a machine that's
very useful for measuring planets and
all this information you want to have
and we find it bomb the ocean uh I
believe it was crushed in some ways we
had to reconstruct with x-rays took us I
really want to figure out how it even
worked and discovered once we realized
this machine is doing all this amazing
stuff that we thought didn't get
invented for another 1500 years in
Europe uh this wild situation where you
have these people in Europe thinking
they're at the state of the art in clock
design and they are over a thousand
years behind something that is rotting
at the bottom of the sea because people
who built that that knowledge was lost
they built it and something happened
they kept it a secret or some disaster
happens the people who knew how to do
this
we're no longer there and the knowledge
of that even that thing existing
evaporated and you're left with people
having to reinvent it and took them
over a thousand years to do it like this
is this to me is the the value of
knowledge the value of
not just having the parts in your hand
but knowing how to put them together
because like the company is my favorite
example it's such a simple invention
it's tying a rock to a string and it
took us so long because it's it just if
you don't have that spark of inspiration
that lucky chance it doesn't necessarily
have to happen and there's a lot of
technologies that we take for granted
but
you don't necessarily need them to do
stuff and they just they evaporate you
don't you don't realize they're gone
it's I mean I'm I'm a big fan of
preserving knowledge because of this but
it's it's such a
I said terrifying in the talk and I
agree with with my past self it's
terrifying to imagine losing something
like writing
what do you do then
it's over well and I mean things like
the Rosetta Stone took 50 years of
decoding just to get back to something
even with parallel scripts which is
always going to be insane to me but so
we're going to go to some audience
questions shortly can I just say I love
how boring the Rosetta Stone is the
actual content of the stone yeah it's
just like the dullest stuff Tax decree
yeah it's it's like
no one would ever want to read this
Stone but it unlocks many languages just
by the fact of its existence
so I know I was like why does no one
talk with the Rosetta Stone what's on it
oh it's boring okay
which we have that so we you know one of
the projects here is this Rosetta desk
and when we were trying to figure out
what was the parallel text to put on
that desk
um a very quick actually you kind of got
to it a little bit in your presentation
my suggestion was it was that it
basically the most translated things are
parts of the Bible and so my thought was
that it should be that the story of
Babel
oh that's fine
um but it turns out
it's very hard to find that because of
where it is in the Bible
um whereas something like the story of
Genesis is very easy because it's always
it's on the first page yeah
um and so people always get a very
offended to learn that we have collected
you know two or three thousand versions
of the story of Genesis is the parallel
text but when they get offended I ask
them what was on the Rosetta stand and
they don't know right you guys can
answer boring tax law don't waste your
time it's a boring Stone yeah
um
one of the things I just want to talk
about so you talked about all these
foods which have evolved so radically
and I thought one of the things that's
funny here we do extinct recipes for
cocktails and the the problem with that
when you read 150 year old book that
says crack one egg into a flip for
instance or egg white or squeeze one
lemon a lemon 150 years ago or a lime
yep
it's a different fruit eggs were also
tiny tiny and so you have to also
de-extinct the the evolution of that
yeah we've had it even recently um if
you don't like brussels sprouts give
them another shot because over the past
20 years they've become much less bitter
uh it's wild because I thought I didn't
like brussels sprouts and like they're
not the same brussels sprouts
um the earliest recipe I could find
was
I think it was a Sumerian uh beer recipe
and the reason it survived was that they
mixed it in with religion and so the
religious texts would survive and this
beer recipe copied and so it's a prayer
to this God of beer saying oh you know I
love you got a beer I love how you take
the grains and put them in a Boiling Pot
of water it's so good I love how you
mash the grains and let it ferment for
30 days we love you so much like it's
like this hack of turning it into a
prayer allowed it to survive you're like
this is just a recipe for beer
all right so we have a question in the
front
but the one that really got me was the
earliest one you mentioned where you go
back to the anatomically modern humans
and in theory they could have invented
language and uh and writing and it I
wonder have you thought about why not
like is it were people just not coming
up with ideas back then it was like oh
no there's these very rare things uh
like where now you would think of what
happened
I think the the challenge is that any
language is only useful if more than one
person speaks it
and so I can be you know caveman
Einstein and invent English but unless I
can both invent it codify it and teach
it
it hasn't have any use like it's just me
walking around babbling effectively so I
think that's part of it I think
honestly it's it's
such a hard problem to solve because you
have to do it alone like it's it's
I don't blame
my answer all of our ancestors and say
my ancestors I don't blame anyone's
ancestors 200 000 years ago for not
figuring that out you look at the
earliest cave paintings and
they have they had written language we
could know what these people thought and
what they thought of the world and
theirselves and what they could dream
about but they didn't so they're just
their hands we know what their hands
look like and you know they look like
our hands like there's not a lot there
you can
I've seen people sort of wax poetic
about you know it's it's so human to see
the shape of the hand and touch it and
it's like yeah but like what were they
talking about like what were they
thinking
why don't I wish I'd written that down
it's it's so hard
so I think the the this is a long answer
simple question but I think it's just
that it's a very hard thing to do on
your own and it's something that doesn't
immediately have a parent use until more
people are speaking it so Ben Gutierrez
from our uh online audience uh Mike gets
to the next person
um yes are there any technological dead
ends that we should avoid
if we were to restart some of these yeah
you know what there's a great one
um
smoking cigarettes smoking tobacco
it's fascinating uh you look at the
death caused by smoking tobacco
even after we know it's a bad idea uh
there are more people killed by tobacco
in the 20th century than there were
in World War one and two combined
there if you want to kill someone like
I've talked with this in how deep of the
world that's super fun if you want to
kill people and get away with it
you know
bombs only can blow up once you know
these shoots many people before you get
shot yourself but like
teaching them to smoke they will happily
you can kill billions of people and not
go to jail for it so if you're going
back in time just knock the first
cigarette or kill the first tobacco
plant out of and you will save
tons and tons of people so another
there's technological data another new
world crop just like yeah
so you started as a computational
linguist and then got to Dinosaur comics
and then now you're spreading all kinds
of comics and things like that could you
just talk a little bit about your
trajectory for possibly people that are
thinking about
maybe not doing the thing they went to
college for and yeah and they love I'm a
big fan of not doing the thing you went
to college for
so I
um
in high school
there was this whole nice I'm sure it's
still the case this idea of you need to
decide what you want your life to be and
set the course of your life and whatever
you do in undergrad will be what you do
in grad school and that'll be what you
do as a job and this the choice you make
now at age 17 will Define the rest of
your life so Choose Wisely and do it in
two weeks and I I hated that and I was
torn between
um
writing and computers and I like them
both and I ended up studying computers
because I thought well I could always
write in my spare time but I'm not sure
I could program in my spare time I could
have but it was just a choice I made
and I started doing my webcomic in
undergrad and kept up through grad
school
and
it became this nice sort of balance
where
the comma could be off doing its own
thing and then when I graduated grad
school we were talking about this
earlier and I said that um
to become a full-time writer I just had
to not get a job which is really easy
and so it was very sort of simple to
slide into
you also had to be successfully doing
the other part yeah but that's I mean
ramp right yeah but I mean this is
anything creative if you if you want to
do something creative my greatest advice
there's two parts of advice the first
advice is uh you really need to decouple
your self-worth from the work you make
because
in most jobs if you work hard you get a
better result but in the Arts you can
work hard and nobody cares and you can
Dash something off that you think is bad
and people love it there's a disconnect
between cause and effect and you can go
crazy trying to figure that out
especially online where you have numbers
and like well why did this get the
bigger number and this got the smaller
number I must Crack the Code there's no
code to crack it's random
so that's piece of ice one and
did I have a second
that was a really good one by the way
yeah gosh
don't get a job
if I think of my second brilliant piece
of advice I will try all right well the
last question that I have for you is is
now that you've figured out how to
reinvent everything and uh take over the
world which is your next book uh what
what are you working on now
trying to remember what my piece of
advice was
aspiring artists
I'm gonna set up like straight in bed at
four in the morning like oh that was it
wear shorts or something
um we can put it in a post yeah we'll
fix it in post yeah
but yeah
wait I want to thank you so much for
coming here but I wanna
give you one of our challenge points oh
my God thank you for the interval and
thank you so much this was a dream come
true thank you so great thank you
thank you all for coming
thank you all
[Music]